Por ello les anuncio que desde ahora
los diputados y diputadas de podemos
pasamos al grupo mixto
para garantizar
nuestra capacidad de hacer política en el congreso
y para seguir impulsando
las medidas valientes
que necesitan las mayorías sociales de este país.
Las personas de podemos
no estamos en política por conservar 1 escaño,
ni por estar en 1 gobierno, ni por calentar 1 sillón.
Estamos aquí en el congreso para impulsar, como digo,
cambios valientes y ambiciosos
para hacer posible lo que nos dicen
que es imposible.
Por ello les anuncio que desde ahora
los diputados y diputadas de podemos
pasamos al grupo mixto
para garantizar nuestra capacidad de hacer política
en el congreso
y para seguir impulsando
las medidas valientes
que necesitan las mayorías sociales de este país.
Las personas de podemos no estamos en